[Music]
Arnold Schwarzenegger has been in the
news recently he has a new autobiography
yet I know you had a guy an
autobiography yeah and in it he reveals
this insane stuff yeah one of the things
a lot of people have picked up on is
that Arnold reveals that when he was
making the Terminator the first of the
Terminator films that he got into an
argument with James Cameron the director
over using the line I'll be back okay a
line that has since become one of the
greatest movie catchphrases of all time
Arnold didn't want to say that right
right Cameron really wanted him to say
I'll be back and Arnold fought it and
fought it and fought it well apparently
before Arnold finally gave in he tried
to do the line his own way and we showed
some of the outtakes last night well
guess what we just found more shut up
yes we did it all right I found them
right I don't can't believe him no one
else has them yeah they were in a
laundry basket they found them let's
take a look at these Arnold trying it a
few different ways I returned later at
the more convenient time I will say
Aloha since it means both hello and
goodbye I would make like a boomerang in
the pier to move away in a linear
fashion only to gradually double back to
this point of origin listen I know
you've been very patient with me up
until now and I wouldn't ask this if it
weren't really important but I have to
pick up someone at the airport and soon
by the dry
before they close if you could possibly
wait here until a little after 7:00 -
right here in the very same spot unless
of course my friends flight gets delayed
or I get stuck in traffic we face is the
real possibility at this time of day
especially with all that construction
they're doing on route 119 anyway I
guess what I'm saying is if you'll hear
you're here and it's or not or not but I
myself will most certainly be returning
here sometime later today I really did
we also found out that Arnold's I guess
he just fights a lot with with Cameron
yeah he also fought James Cameron over
the line hasta la vista baby yeah and he
tried his own versions of that line as
well hasta manana boo boo hasta luego
dum dum pasta alfredo in cake potato
potato
Bigfoot abracadabra
buttface
[Applause]
Cadabra buttface you like a break you
like a look at everybody